well tonight lebron add another
milestone
to your resume passing derek fisher
becoming the nba's all-time
leader in playoff wins i know you have
said time and time again you'll reflect
on those milestones later
but to play at the level you're playing
at and achieve that milestone and you're
17
what does that say about what you're
trying to accomplish
um it says that i've played with a lot
of great teams
it says that i play with a lot of great
teammates and some great coaches
you know either in cleveland in miami
and now here in los angeles
you don't get those wins without your
teammates so and the coaching staff that
prepares and do all the preparation
that's behind the scenes the video
coordinators the
uh the guys who help rebound the
basketballs for us
the assistant coaches the trainers the
athletic staff um so on and so on so
um it doesn't happen without the
supporting cast and
it's why i'm able to sit here with this
achievement but
it's all about the three organizations
i've been with the cavs the heat and now
the lakers because without them i
wouldn't be in this position
last thing i'll ask you about i know
coach vogel keeps on telling us
that he is going to use the memory of
kobe bryant to fuel this playoff run and
continue to talk to the team about it
how have you channeled that to motivate
you through this
run through the postseason in this most
unique environment at the end of the day
we just hope we make him and his family
proud
and that's all it's about and anybody
that's ever stepped foot
and put on the lakers jersey we hope we
make them proud as well from kobe all
the way down to everybody that's ever
played in los angeles have been a part
of los angeles
lakers organization that's what we're
trying to do it's a tradition here
and it's our responsibility win lose a
draw to hold that with the most
responsibility
and utmost respect and you know that's
what dr bus will want as well